[Applause]
surprise
cardi b just revealed she's pregnant
during her performance at the bet awards
on sunday the rapper's sparkly bodysuit
perfectly showed off her blinged out
baby bump as she performed alongside
migos
who gave us this tiny clue before the
performance
what are you gonna do tonight what will
we see tonight uh the most electrifying
show on earth you know i'm saying
the amigo's gonna break the stage the
greatest group alive mo ice mo dripping
mo mo mo everything just stay tuned
tonight
following the performance blackish star
marsai martin had
this to say um
okay barty with the baby bump
oh my god okay
around the same time as this reveal
cardi took to instagram to confirm
she's expecting her second child with
husband offset
she posted this stunning maternity photo
and wrote simply
number two adding a heart and tagging
hubby offset
there's some big big things on the way
big bangs and in the comments khloe
kardashian said congratulations
and chloe bailey wrote wow beautiful and
if this live tv reveal seems familiar
there's a good reason oh yes honey the
couple welcomed
two-year-old daughter culture in 2018
and cardi announced the good news while
performing on saturday night live
listen this loves got you this messed up
in the bag
you want a random
and the happy surprise added to an
already joyful night
cardi was nominated for five bet awards
including
two nominations for video of the year
for her songs [ __ ]
and up the b-e-t award goes
too i mean the camera
cardi b featuring magnus down
i don't know i just get too emotional
when it comes to my kid cardi opened up
to et about how she navigates both
stardom
and being a mom as your career gets
bigger and bigger
how are you feeling about stardom is it
everything that you
thought it was going to be is it harder
better it's
definitely harder like the more money
the more problems the more people
um that that things they know you
and their opinions it just gets harder
people don't understand some people
don't understand the
the struggle some people don't
understand the work that i put in so
they will just always try to
think that it came easy for me how are
you balancing
everything and are you experiencing that
mom guilt a little bit
i do experience that mom guilt you know
she's like oh my gosh all that traveling
and i know her sleeping schedule is
getting a little messed up
and i know every single time that she
get on an airplane
it's all good and to the landing she
starts crying and i just be feeling so
sad because it's like i know the pain
you know when your ears pop
i just be so sad and like sometimes i
wake up in the morning
and like she's in my bed and i just want
to cuddle with this